this is curt novena reading for justin
clark
if you've ever worked a job where your
bosses are the worst people imaginable
a job where they ask you to fix a
problem using broken tools
and then blame you for the result then
you have a pretty good idea of what it's
like to play the ascent
that's not just a metaphor either it's
literally
the baked in plot of the game it's the
far off future and you must sign away
your freedom to become an indentured
servant to various corporate masters in
order to escape
the velas an intergalactic project block
for all the galaxy's huddled masses
yearning to breathe free
in the first area of gameplay you're
forced to clean veloz's toilets by
fixing the sewage system by the time the
credits roll
even hours after mowing down scumbags
watching your character become a metal
monster and running odd jobs for weirdos
and strangers
it's hard to feel like you've worked
your way up from those starting sewers
the small blessing is that the job
involves fewer plungers and more
heavy sci-fi weaponry and cybernetic
enhancements
the ascent is a twin stick shooter with
a slew of rpg elements thrown in for
flavor
there's an impressive and unique
assortment of pistols shotguns assault
rifles and rocket launchers here
each of which can attack enemy
weaknesses for extra damage
each of the weapons also have very
different practical feels in game
armor has a similarly expansive variety
with the added benefit of changing your
character's look
to an increasingly mechanical degree
it's not great that most of those armor
pieces obscure your custom-made
character but the designs
are incredibly cool you'll also gain
special abilities along the way
such as a hydraulic powered melee attack
and deadly drone companions
who can fight by your side you'll be
spending most of your time running and
gunning through what are essentially
expansive rpg style dungeons where
combat has more in common with contra
than diablo when your mission is done
you can head back to one of the game's
bustling
shopping districts to spend skill points
on various character stats
as well as buy upgrades new items and
new cybernetic toys to splice into
yourself
the ascent can occasionally be a game of
simple splattery joy where you waste an
endless parade of mutants
and cyborgs for hours on end the ascent
hits its stride when you're actually
well equipped and your armor protects
you just enough to make overwhelming
odds a source of caution instead of
panic but those stretches are hard to
come by
the second you create your character and
step off the first platform to get
yelled at by
feces coming out of your boss's shower
it's already anything but a good time
cyberpunk as a genre wallows in dystopia
sprawling neon mega cities obscuring
dirt grime
bodily waste and horror are the genres
bread and butter
the ascent is no different and as a
sheer visual achievement the design of
velas is striking
every square inch of the place is
teeming with unique visual elements
distinctive npcs
expressive and unique enemy types and a
tangible sense
of technological splendor gone sour
you're surrounded by hostile alien
species
unthinkable technology and ongoing civil
rest at all times the whole place feels
like a 90s image comic version of heavy
metal
it's all the trappings and cliches of
hard sci-fi
rendered as full mouthed edgy and
needlessly aggressive as possible
it's an excellent rendition of a place
you don't want to spend any extended
time in
but you will and much of that time will
be spent
dying
make no mistake the ascent is a tough
game in any one given area
the critical path forward will lead you
through a kill zone with 30 trash mob
mutants who can mow you down in seconds
but then we'll
follow up immediately with a room of
absolute bullet sponges who can cut you
down in seconds despite being your exact
experience level and
despite you using the weapon the enemy
should be weak to
one of the biggest bottlenecks early in
the game involves returning to the
afromentioned sewers
to re-route power to your boss's
neighborhood you spend five minutes
turning lowly mutants into minced meat
then another hour getting pulverized by
an army of new robot enemies
who you are thoroughly unprepared to
face the game doesn't really communicate
that robots are weak to energy weapons
and once you've sussed that out
you probably don't have a terribly
effective one on hand
so you head back to town buy a few
energy based weapons and watch as you
still get destroyed in seconds
it's all too easy to stroll into an
absolute death trap 15 to 20 minutes
into a dungeon
then half the stroll all the way out to
get better prepared
even that isn't as easy as it sounds
considering stores stop carrying useful
gear about halfway through the game
bounty missions and menial side quests
provide only a paltry amount of extra
cash
and checkpoints are still few and far
between
granted the load times were fairly quick
on pc so your other option is constantly
bashing your head against the wall
retrying a challenge
without any real consequence and keeping
the xp
all the way but there are deep
difficulty spikes in this game and
having to stop every few hours to grind
stops the game's fun dead in its tracks
even if the ascent was fully functional
and balanced in a way where building up
a character to become the ultimate
warrior
there's the fact that so much of the
game is designed to feel like servitude
as you climb the superstructure housing
all of velas you serve a progression of
masters
and the payoff of the game's central
mystery isn't nearly enough to offset
the hopeless grind
your bosses insult you when you go on
your task ignore you when you've done
well
and provide no rewards for success
there's just so little joy from a game
playing in a genre that typically excels
at it pretty easily
for so much of the playtime the ascent
feels like well
an uphill battle
[Music]
you